every year's the big man himself this is
going to be sick
yes yes
what is happening
how are you doing it's been a long last
time he was here we were doing
evictions there right man come on
through bro
surreal being back here the last time i
was here was like little sweaty pigs and
feet inside the board we were under
pressure
yeah it's a lot more chilled chilled now
now you're guessing a friend hey what's
up guys welcome back to my channel
this week we have one of the most
incredible stories
you will hear in your entire life i want
to introduce you to a guy you probably
already know who he is
called lawton hopwood from hopwood homes
he has over the last 12 months
done ridiculous things in property he's
gone from codial sourcing
to sourcing to becoming a developer now
he is crushing it
making serious amounts of money he's one
of the most inspiring guys that i know
and lawton welcome to winners on a
wednesday
thank you for i feel like that is a
round of applause
i was like getting hyped up listening to
who's this guy who's this guy
how did it feel when you walked when you
walked in here this morning all right it
was a bit
i walked in i was like the last time i
was here it was through the eviction and
i was like
nervous i was sweating all the time and
eventually i didn't know what was going
on it kind of brought loads of
flashbacks back but they realized like
we've done that now new season yeah it's
chilled now
new team well listen i'm sure people
watching this have got an idea who you
are
maybe they've seen the eviction maybe
they've seen the financial freedom
challenges that i've
we've done together but for anyone that
doesn't why don't you just walk through
and tell us how this how this all
started yeah of course so obviously
he's introduced me as lauren hopwood i
came into samuel's life probably what
was it the 22nd of june last year
yeah i'd have been made redundant for my
job i had a well-paid uh
corporate job that i thought that was my
career but i've always had
interest in property got made redundant
messaged samuel and just said look
i've been watching your stuff for a
solid week
i've done 11 viewings i've put offers in
two properties
and i had built didn't add built um like
a buyer's pack
an investor's package from your videos
and i said do you mind just over
having a look at it and just checking to
make sure that it looks right and he was
like looks good professional looks sick
bro
keep going so that from the start there
led me to
post it on social media like i said
viewing plenty of houses i was trying to
call the old source to make a living
don't forget i just been made redundant
in a global pandemic
which you know my carpet the rug
underneath me had been pulled from
and i was literally like [ __ ] myself
so your job
prior to getting made redundant was what
i was a project manager for a
construction company so i overseen
builds such as
city west tower in manchester uh
apartments and
small developments as well now at the
time when you got made redundant you
didn't tell anybody
no why i couldn't bear it i just
couldn't
a lot of it was a bit of pride as well
you know but i couldn't
bear the thought of having somebody say
you know put their arm around my back
and say you know
it's all right law and you'll you'll
find your feet again you'll get another
job
i didn't want that i kind of wanted
somebody to say look lord and this is
your chance now
yeah you've got a moment to sink or swim
you can change your life if you do
something
and that was the sort of voice i had in
my head yeah i didn't want anybody
asking my mum
the only person who knew was was my
partner rachel and and even
rachel was like nervous don't get me
wrong i was nervous and everything i did
moving forward was fearless yeah i was
so afraid of losing my house
maybe a fall out of my of my
relationship losing my son just i
thought everything was the worst
because i had no money i had no income
you kept it from your son
didn't tell him didn't tell him anything
so you're in the situation and one of
the
your catchphrases that we um when you're
not around we say
is you used to say a lot i don't want
this
i need this yeah yeah but that was your
that was your kind of
state right then you'd be made redundant
now to be fair you could have got
another job
yeah in fact you were not offered
necessarily but you you had options to
get another job but you
you turned that down because why because
well so
you know what i got maybe done the uh
the industry
got word that i've been made and you
know i'm i'm i was good at my job
i built very very strong relationships
with people within the industry and they
were ringing me saying look
i know what's happened to you i've heard
someone else has told me
we're looking for hiring child homework
with us so i could have moved myself
from that sort of what the hell am i
doing in my life
part back into a really comfortable you
know well-paid job company car company
phone and all the rest of it i could
have done that
like this but i knew that wasn't what i
wanted long term
i knew that it was a moment to change my
life and that was the be all end all and
that was that saying you know
i don't need this opportunity like
you don't want it yeah yeah other way
around yeah but listen
the opportunity and disappointment are
two things that will always happen we'll
have disappointments of opportunity
when you got made redundant i mean what
state were you
how did you feel when you first found
out you made it undone it was like
breaking up with a girlfriend when you
were
18. the heart my heart just sank i was
just like
my heart dropped i filled with blood and
i was just like
[ __ ] what am i gonna do yeah and i know
for a fact that i'm not the only person
that went through that situation in that
time as well because
you know you look at the news and there
was millions of people in the uk that
went through the same thing
yeah and i don't know exactly how they
felt yeah and they know watching this
they know how i felt it's the worst
feeling you can have when
you work paycheck to paycheck you know
you live to your means
yeah your car your house it all goes to
the what year was this this was last
year
what what month sorry uh it was june i
got toured 2020. so i got told in june
2020
about 24 if it was or something like
that and then i had uh
four weeks of garden leave so my last
pay
yeah from my job was july you messaged
me i think june 26
yeah 2020 june 26 i could even find the
message
and you and you you said i've just been
made redundant i've booked a lot of
viewings
i'm binge watching your youtube videos
can you help me out
i was like cool we chatted and i said
you need to join samuel 365.
yeah which i did i did i was already
actually on it though
you said you need to join something for
yourself i was already on it because the
moment i got made redundant in june
i got off that zoom call i went
downstairs i told rachel
look this has happened she knew
something bad happened because i was
probably white
as a ghost and i just went back upstairs
on my laptop
and i was straight away this is no lie i
logged on to your
365 and i signed up for the week and
from that moment
watched all your videos straight for a
week and i just went out there and put
in massive massive action what's the
difference between the youtube channel
and samuel 365. will you get the course
don't you get the you get the online
course which i thought was brilliant
because i could watch it because i
couldn't get to one neither
because that was my first thing i'm
gonna go to one of these you know your
crash courses but because i was in the
lockdown
it had stopped so i could watch the
course which i thought was brilliant
which me i didn't even know what an roi
was i collect the roi by the total
amount invested by
the amount that you're getting out
divided by 100
times 100 sorry i didn't know how to
calculate it or anything so these sort
of like what i think now is a simple
thing
was a massive thing i was like let me
just pause it let me write that down
again yeah
you know because it was such a big
learning curve for me so watching the
crash caution you've got the deal
finding extravaganza on there aren't you
right the dfe
i watched that as well and i thought
right from
watching this i know i can go out there
and do the basics how much does it cost
you to sign up to samuel 365 a quid a
pound
a freaking quid a pound so you you paid
a pound now it's a pound for seven days
and it's 95 pound a month
unlimited mentoring unlimited support
it's ridiculous
it's it's listen for me that quid was
everything
yeah like i put that pound on there just
being made
i watched it everything that i needed to
watch i watched it in that one week
i spent like i don't know let's say 10
10 12 hours on it a day
no i was just like rachel just leave me
to it me just i can't play with you i
need to do this yeah
close the door i was watching it i was
making notes making notes making notes
every day
from early morning to late at night i
was just finishing now i saw you you
kept like posting
uh little snacks uh stories on instagram
out doing properties
you were doing a bit of cody or sourcing
um around sort of like july august
september time yeah
what did you do in those three months
prior to
things getting real like what what did
what what did you do
so like you said i was called the old
source and that was keeping my head
above water what does curdle sourcing
mean so cordial saucy means where i will
go out and i will find a property i will
find a deal
but i don't have an investor to buy it
so i'll contact somebody who does have
investors
i'll pass him the deal and he'll do the
selling for me and then
we'll split the fee so basically you're
a deal sorcerer without any
investors without any skills of being
able to sell the deal yeah without
having to have any contracts without
having to have any compliance
any compliance but you're getting paid a
smaller amount because the actual deal
source is taking some of the profit yeah
exactly
so you did a few of those deals and that
was kind of just about keeping your head
above the power pit right
absolutely and then you applied for the
eviction
got declined i think so did you get
declined so
i i applied for it but then it
he needed to do a video and i was like
right i'll do the video later
and that's the worst thing that anyone
can do yeah i'll do it later because
later never comes
and i didn't end up doing that video but
then i was out on a saturday night
having
having a meal because i'd been making a
little bit of money i sold a few deals
so we went out and enjoyed
a bit of food yeah and then i had a text
message from you on your instagram
it must've been about r7 on a saturday
night saying hey look are you interested
in joining eviction which actually by
the way warned me it was amelia yeah
yeah
whatever but emilia reached out because
i didn't even know this from my
perspective
i've got 12 people on the eviction all
is good i'm like grant looking forward
to it
then emilia contacted me about two days
before and said we're in a lockdown
lots of people have got covered a lot of
people are scared to leave the house
and there's a few people that have
dropped off what'd you want me to do
i said i want 12 people she said how are
we going to find the people
i said just choose anyone
just pick people so amelia now who's my
um brand and talent manager
had like 24 hours when
what did what what what happened when
emilia spoke to you like what was
because it's
this is a crazy story because you had
the opportunity of a lifetime
but it was a big decision with a big
sacrifice what happened so
she messes me on saturday 7 30 saying
look you want to come in eviction and i
was like
i just i just messaged back and i think
it was as simple as yes
i mean yeah i mean yes i mean that was
it and then she messing about straight
away saying okay cool
um are you available for the month of uh
november and i said yes i mean and then
she said again saying okay cool the only
other thing is it starts tomorrow i said
yes i'm in
and then she put oh just one more thing
it's in london
can you come here tomorrow at uh two i
said
yes i'll see you there send me the
address yeah and then i was like
hey rach um what are you doing tomorrow
cause i'm gonna need the car i need to
go to london
so you came from a drop of a hat and
then pretty much straight after
i think it was two days after that yeah
we was in it because that was you got
that message right before the end of
october yeah yeah
so so suddenly you've got to give up an
entire month
who says that are you afraid in the
month of november which starts in three
days time
oh and also to come to london tomorrow
like so you're like yes yes yes yes yes
what's the lesson in that the lesson in
it is don't think too much about
something
if you see an opportunity come your way
you just need to jump at it you need to
take massive action
if you dwindled on it and if i had took
an hour and thought about it i'd asked
my cat i'd ask my dog and ask me mrs my
mom can i go and do it
i could have messaged back and said okay
i mean and then emilia could have
messaged me saying
oh sorry it's been filled that happened
to lots of people yeah
you know because it's like are you free
space is available space is available
yes yes yes
and boom so i saw you the following day
i didn't even know you were coming yeah
yeah we'd spoke on instagram a little
bit
just a little if not we never met in
person you're on 365.
so suddenly a drop of a hat you're there
what happened
we got dropped off in in the uh the
hotel it was supposed to be just like a
bit of a briefing something casual
like a dinner and then all of a sudden
it was like boom
we're actually starting it today so it
starts now you know literally
we begin right now no messing it's
happening
we're on like it's starting today like
it's not a brief
we're starting it today this is the
challenge
and i was just like wow this is real
and i knew from that moment that making
that fast decision and i could see
the decisions that you was making just
being with you for that probably a
couple of hours you were making
decisions like this yeah all the time so
i knew that i'd done the right thing
what did you think when the first person
got evicted it's tough for me
dude with regret you're evicted
i couldn't believe it to be fair like
what happened do you remember oh
on so we got the training didn't we yeah
we got the training
and we had to come back we had to
complete the training
we all arrived and then there was one
girl one that did that come
late so you said look be back at london
at this time two o'clock so you know i
get there at probably like ten past
one there's a mcdonald's on the corner
i've got loads of time i'm chilling
and then come say like 20 past two or
whatever when it was supposed to be
there for two
that girl um anisia yeah yeah
walks in and i was like oh [ __ ] and then
we got into the room and then all of a
sudden it was like so
if once we come in um why you late and i
was just like
uh-oh and he was like excuse after
excuses
excuses it was just like basically i'm
sorry but you're you're evicted
yeah you can't carry on yeah it was just
like wow this
is real it was like the dinner was a
briefing
but didn't turn it up to be a challenge
the first time back
for the challenge people were just
getting dropped like flies one after mel
was the first person you know
yeah we had for the training he didn't
finish his training it's like you didn't
finish training man you had one job yeah
we got here
you're evicted yeah off you go yeah
people were just shocked yeah everyone
i remember sat at the desk and i looked
and i looked at fazzafas went
and i was like yeah because there's
youtube samuel leads
and then there's business samuel leads
and and youtube samuel leeds might be
like hey what's up
but then in business it's bang bang bang
fast but i don't think people realize
that when you're acting like that and
you're being fast
what you're actually doing is you're
showing an example of how you've got to
be in real life
yeah because you do need to make fast
decisions in real life if i didn't make
that fast decision in my real life
i wouldn't have been on the eviction
yeah now if you didn't evict somebody so
quickly you want to set a president for
everybody else
yeah and then that moment i knew this is
not a game
yeah this is real this is a real
competition and i need to knuckle down
so that whole month give me a summary of
what happened that month
on the eviction i'm stressed i'm
stressed on their behalf
i'm confident we're going to win you've
got till then to sell that deal i would
recommend you sell it tonight and you
get the money in your bank tonight
i've just secured a deal in warrington
tonight's going to be
hard it was a whirlwind it was an
emotional roller coaster it was
incredible amount of learning we got put
through the holy academy
you know we had the lease option boot
camp which was sick i ended up walking
away with six lease options
from that you know it was it was
incredible and
it's funny as well because on the uh
eviction out of those six lease options
that i
secured i ended up selling one of him to
evans
well evans bought one off was so i still
got two of him
and then i saw the rest of him
afterwards as well the rest of the
eviction
you know people getting dropped left
right and center and then it was the
last three of us we had that big reef
up in durham which was you know that was
great that made me
also realize that you know property
investing whether it's deal sourcing
project management looking after other
people's money or other people's assets
us in there in that property looking
after your asset and doing it to that
standard that we did
i just realized that this is something
that i need to be doing
right like it just made it like don't
get me wrong i was clear before but this
made it crystal clear yeah that i wanted
to do it so during the month of the
eviction then
skills highlight we spent a lot of time
together hardcore
intense it was honestly like i like
we'll go on to it when we get to the ff
challenge as well but like i thought
that i worked hard
come the eviction with deadlines set for
like
four hours in front of you and you're
like okay i need to go
now yeah it makes you really work it
makes you sweat put it that way it makes
you
would you do the eviction again 100 100
i would but if you're gonna do it you
need to have a little bit of something
about you because
it's graphed yeah like it's hard graphic
yeah
the level of the learning and the
training that you get coupled with the
hard work and the graft
like you could be unstoppable absolutely
so you got through to the
to the finals yes and the actual [ __ ]
the violet is still ongoing
yeah yeah which is crazy because the the
ultimate prize is the millionaire
challenge so yeah he's gonna become a
millionaire yeah
that is to come but the three of you one
of you was going to win
an ff challenge i was evans yourself and
david and i ended up i liked all three
of you so much i just said
i'm going to do a financial freedom
change of all of you so i pretty much
back to back
lived with evans for a week helped him
become financially free
they did the same thing with you the
same thing with david in that
week i think that was probably even a
bigger game changer to the eviction
potential i don't know i mean
what happened in the week yeah for me it
was because
you know i got to see what you was like
in real person i got to see your work
ethic
but for you to actually spend that week
with me from the morning we wake up to
the morning we go to bed
and i can see how switched on you are
again i just said it before about the
eviction i thought it worked hard until
i went to the eviction
then my level stepped up from the
eviction i thought i worked hard
until i went on to the ff challenge
review and then i realized
that is how i need to be everything that
you were doing everything on your phone
everything was laser focused to business
oh yeah and create an opportunity yeah
nothing else mattered and it made me
realize that that's exactly how i need
to be to be
able to be anything in my life to be
successful yeah interesting
it's a really really hard week it was a
full-on lockdown
because a lot of people saying are you
going to cancel the financial freedom
challenge because we've just gone into
an
absolute nation lockdown we couldn't
even get fish and chips
no we couldn't even couldn't get it
anywhere we couldn't get meetings with
agents you know we were trying to talk
to them through letterboxes
yeah we were literally we were just
totally
destitute it was it was hard however
what did we achieve that week and then
i'm going to ask you what you went on to
do afterwards yeah sure so
that week i mean we spent a couple days
doing the rent to rents we
we failed miserably at them rental rents
but then we switched plan we switch
strategies which again is a learning
curve you know
if something isn't going your way if
you're looking at properties in a
certain price bracket then just change
go for a bigger price bracket go for a
smaller price bracket so we changed that
strategy we adopted the um the selling
sort of deal sourcing
we got a handful literally a handful of
deals
and then within what is it let's say
two hours yeah posting it out in the
evening
text text text
are people wanting to buy the deals off
you text text i'm interested i'm
interested i'm interested
i remember you having my phone and i
might have gone upstairs
go to the bathroom came downstairs and
you're like lauren come here come
downstairs and you just show me the
phone it was just like i'm interested
i'm interested i'm interested i'm
interested in just i was like
oh my god please don't forget that was
the first time that i'd even seen that
as well
because all the deals i've done prior
were co-deal sourced so i'd never seen
that that power
yeah of sending an email out to somebody
and then having like 20 30 people
messaging you saying that they're
interested in a deal
and to me that i was looking at all
those text messages thinking that's
pound signs
yeah like gobsmacked
yeah and we ended up making how much you
make that week 11 grand
11 grand in a week bang in cash 11
and we secured some deals for yourself
one of those being
the the development deal that you're now
working on yeah which
is just a banger so
tell me about that deal so how's it
going bob is the deal going going ahead
yeah so it's all signed it's all
contracted so technically like you know
i own that land now that's an asset of
mine and then we'll be getting
development finance on that but the
money be dropping in our account
probably in the next couple of weeks but
three weeks time
anytime we'll have an excavator on site
starting it oh mate
so i'm super excited so you're gonna be
building six houses six
which will be making you six figures
easy easy
easy you've done that with zero money no
believe it or not
no money down none of my own money has
ever been spent
to get this going to get to get an
actual
you know a 30-ton digger on site it's
not cost me any money yeah
unbelievable absolutely awesome now the
week before the ff challenge
i did train you on the development deep
dive
yeah talk to me about that there's so
much this is like it's almost like
it's like a flashback for me this is a
social experiment
okay because you've actually like
kind of almost been chosen you know i
mean like normally
if people want to do a financial freedom
challenge with me they can't
and if people want to do the training
and the academy they've got to pay for
it and it's
it's a hefty investment yeah but you
know with you and a few other people it
with evans and david it's like let's do
a social experiment
let me just mentor this person and give
them some training they've got to work
for it yeah they've got to show that
they can work hard and show they can
turn up on time and
they've got to be a grafter they've got
to want it and it's got to burn it's
like a social experiment i'm like i'll
put you on this course i'll put you on
this course i'll send you here let me do
a bit of training with you i'll go and
live with you for a week
um and and part of that was the
development deep dive
yeah now foreign doesn't know i'm a
developer
and i've been developer for quite a long
time now and i make a lot of my money
today in property development and
it's quite a niche most most people want
to start a bit deal sourcing or rent to
rents or
about to let but a lot of people don't
want to go on to development so i
trained some of my advanced students on
development but i just threw you right
in at the deep end and went like come
and do our development deep dive
training
you came on the train and it was at the
castle yeah lasted a couple of days
what happened it was it was when you've
invited us down to come and do this
course
i was like and you i was like remember
when you was off school for like half
term
and you got a new pencil case a new
rubber a new
pencil i was like that kid going into
that castle i was like this is the
course that i want
because my end goal has always been i
want to be a developer right
i've always had this company name
of hotwood homes group it's a great name
by the way thank you
brandon yeah i've always had this image
of
you know i want to be a developer i want
to build like luxury homes i want to
build gated communities with beautiful
sea or river face views i wanted to
build
just exquisite buildings yeah i love
architecture i love to build i've been a
project manager
i've helped build skyscrapers i've got a
good understanding of the industry
yeah so when you said come down to the
development d-dive i was like
this is my jam we got there i mean the
castle we walked down that
gorgeous sort of walkway towards castle
and everything's symmetrical in front of
you it's just like
wow this is a freaking big building we
went on a tour on it which was great
it's showing us all the sort of ups and
downs of it
you know the amount of money the
investment has to go involved all the
planning and things i was like this
is where my ears perk up because this is
my interest
we did the training again solid days 10
hour days
yeah you know from from early morning
till late at night two days
uh training all the secrets
all the tips all the software this is
what you should be doing
so i was just like writing it down
writing it down and write it down i
remember
there was a projector on the on the wall
with with i don't know whose laptop it
was
but i had all their favorites you know
on the uh on the screen yeah
i remember getting my phone and taking a
picture going well whatever their
favorites is my
favorites right need to be the same yeah
and it was all the sights and we went
through it and shown us all the tips and
the tricks
i remember coming out of it going i
could not go
past a rundown or burnt down pub or
building commercial building without
looking at it and going
that could be something yeah and you
suddenly start driving past sightseeing
that's it that's interesting that's
i just took you to one of my sites just
now yeah you just went for that that was
nice
in beckensfield yeah that's what i mean
like now with the training and the
knowledge like you can't see what you've
been taught
so whereas i might have walked around
like this now after the development deep
dive it's like
i've got full-on vision yeah i'll drive
down like even here
i was driving through beckons field and
i was like oh some of you seen that
building it's got the for sale
yeah yeah i've already seen it been
there done it
yeah and like you can't not see it after
you've had that kind of training because
it just opened you up a little bit more
absolutely and also after that training
because i think that was the week before
rff challenge or there and they're about
yeah yeah yeah about it's about that
yeah about that same so coming
coming away from that i've done it now
i'm driving home i'm coming back from
birmingham
and i'm thinking i do know of sights
it was rattling my brain i couldn't
think of where these sights were
i could envision myself driving past it
like every week though
where is it it's local to me went home
probably must have got back about half
ten couldn't sleep i was so excited it
was on right move i was searching for
this land that i
keep seeing in my mind that i've been
going past and had found it
it's probably about 10 minutes away from
me i thought right brilliant
it's on it's on it's online it's on the
right move it was been listed for
not not too long but i've been on for
long enough
the next day dropped mason off at school
and just drove straight to the site
i thought you know again it's action
isn't it it's
it's taking what i've learned and
implementing it and putting in massive
action
i drove to the site thinking oh the
landowner's just there he's probably
just hanging about his own land you know
i got onto site and there was a lad on
site so i jumped out of the car
went over introduced myself and said
look i'm interested in buying this
landscape you don't happen to know who
owns it do you yeah it's my uncle
so i was like wow built a bit of rapport
with him had a good chat he showed me
around he walked me around
hit the land he walked me around the
yard that he uses for it just to like
build cars and things
and told me the full back story of it
and i said is there any chance
i said i know it's cheeky i said there's
any chance to get his mobile number and
can i just speak to him directly and
hopefully i can do something with him
yeah he was more than happy to pass his
mobile number from there
and then you know from there to where we
are now was
multiple multiple meetings trust
building and it's
well i remember when because the
obviously the the clinching of the deal
the big deal was when we were doing our
challenge yeah and you said to me like
you were trying to do rent to rent we're
banging ahead of a brick wall and you're
like i just want to do development
that was the lockdown but part of that
might have been the fact that you wanted
to do development so bad
i think there was a tiny part maybe
you'll disagree where you might have
even been sabotaging
the rendering slightly a little bit
probably you weren't as hungry for it
yeah probably yeah because my interest
was
has never really be even been in the
event of nc yeah now i just feel like
the things that i want are
much bigger yeah and better and i
remember you saying to me
i'm not bothered about having a passive
income of 2-3 grand a month right now
i want to work my ass off yeah i want to
make lots of money and i want to have
big development deals
returns aren't we drop rent to rent i
was like right
let's find some development deals it's
fine of course you'd already had
multiple sites that you'd identified
off the training the week before yeah we
could potentially go here and then and
then we um
we landed we met up with the guy i
didn't even go in no and
that's the thing because i thought you
was coming with me
and you know you were like i remember
you saying to me something like i feel
like a dad at school just letting him
off in the gate on his own for the first
time it was like
i'd have been with you off camera you've
been speaking to me lord you've been
giving me loads of tips this is how you
should structure it
this is the best thing to do and i was
like right fair play i got that
and then on the day we were driving
there and you just went i think you
should go in on your own
and i was like you sure so it's bang on
good luck
i feel a bit sick to be fair to your
real life yeah you don't get anything to
lose
i know i know i know and that's the way
i'm looking at it because
like this opportunity if i can get on
with this person
and get this deal to build these six
houses like this is like the
dream and you're like yeah do it and i
thought you know what
if samuel believes in me i should be
believing in myself as well
so went in there done the meeting come
out and i was just like to be fair i was
a bit like
overwhelmed with it with with sheer
relief and just like oh my god i can't
even believe i've done it
to be even super excited and you're
jumping about going
mad like oh my god i can't believe you
did it and i was just like
me i can't believe i did it yeah yeah so
you structured
how did you structure that deal then and
how was it how was it a no money down
deal for you
so so basically the land was on the land
had planning permission
the land had everything already there
needed it was a full product
and it was being sold i went in for the
first couple of meetings to try and
negotiate the price
let's say for example the price was half
a million quid i was trying to
and don't forget you've got to put
yourself in my shoe as well i'm going
into meetings with people
who are way above me and i'm trying to
negotiate buying their land
for half a million pound when i've not
even got half a million quid
so i mean so that on its own is a
psychological thing you've got to get
yourself around so i was doing multiple
meetings on my own on my own
building this rapport and i was just
listening to
from the training ask questions never
never
never finish a sentence with a full stop
finish your sentence with a question
yeah keep them talking and i did i kept
him talking
i was asking him all the questions i
needed to know from him and then i
started to realize he had pr
had pain points pressure points and i
thought hold on
he's trying to develop it himself he's a
money man
okay he just told me that he tried to
look he dabbled in he tried to develop
himself but he just doesn't have the
time he's got multiple businesses that
he oversees now and he hasn't really
even got an interest in it
but the person who we tried to do it
with or had a conversation with was just
the money man as well
yeah none of them are developers none of
them have got experience when you say
money man what do you mean so like
they're both really successful
businessmen but
not in property they don't get
development no they don't understand
no appraiser site work at the gdp get
the planning exactly exactly
they didn't get any of that right so i
thought geez
if i present him an opportunity where
it's a hands-off for him
he can still get his land but at the
back end
with a percentage of the profit this
could be really attractive to him
yeah and that is the structure of the
deal he agreed that he agreed to take
the
full payment for the land at the back
end of the day when we sell all the
units so after they've been
erected developed and then sold he'll
take his fee for the land
and then he'll take a percentage of the
profits yeah and then the rest of the
profits is shared between so it's like a
lease option joint venture combined
absolutely yeah yeah and that's
something on the development deep dive
that you go through don't you yeah you
go through jv's
so that was the first time i'd heard
about it setting up a company
get a director if they've got the land
they can bring the land in
and i was just like a lot of the
strategies that
apply to small deals like lease options
i've been doing these options for over a
decade
on little houses to begin with and then
you can scale it up and you think
actually i could do this on
three houses i could do this on a pizza
landing build a block and it's
you know so and same with joint ventures
you could do a joint venture on a small
deal or on a big deal yeah it's the same
yeah it's just a little bit of a
different bag a bit of a different beast
so you got that deal after the financial
freedom challenge
did you just continue with the deal and
a bit of deal sorting or have you
stepped up a whole new level since like
what's happened
yeah so i mean i mean where'd you go
from from a development you know
my first ever development that i got was
a six new builds
with gorgeous you know riverside views
the whole development is going to be
worth about 2.4 million yeah
you know once it's finished and i was
like
crystal clear knowing that development
is where i want to be yeah but you've
got to remember from a business point of
view
developments take a long time right take
nine months before you get your money
yeah
so i thought to myself well within one
year if i can have
three or four developments going on but
then i'm still deal sourcing every month
because i love the old sourcing i love
the hustle
i love the graft of finding new
properties i love negotiating i love
dealing with the builders and the
refurbs and things like that
so i thought if i get three or four of
them big ones over the year that'd be
that
that'd be amazing but then i'll do deal
sourcing every month that just brings in
money you know and to be fair the amount
of deals that i've been doing over the
past well
past four months now it's about five or
six a month
yeah and how much on average you
charging for a deal about
it range between three and a half and
four so you're all making about what
10 15 grand about 20 25 grand wow
20 25 grand a month just from just from
deal sourcing alone and
that doesn't even include what i'll get
on to in a minute which is i've just saw
the portfolio
for 1.8 million which was 26 houses
that's just been signed for this week as
well
right so the fee on that is you know was
three percent of one point
36 grand some serious dollar what was 36
grand sorry
the portfolio that we just sold oh wow
so 36 thousand pounds for that
and then we've got a meeting on this
monday
for for some land that we're selling
that's 1.3 so the profit in that for me
is going to be about 50.
one of the things i used to pull you up
on six months ago
was used to say and you remember when
you used to have a meeting you used to
say we
and i'm like who's we dude it's just you
man what are you talking about
and you said no no i want to feel like
i'm part of something a bit bigger
yeah well like now your hopwood homes
have you if not when will you be taking
on your first member of staff
so yeah definitely be taking on some
staff it's got to the point where
you know managing my own diary is
getting difficult you know
it's getting hectic so yeah i'd be
looking at taking on
people to help us with the deal sourcing
for sure and i'll be
hopefully then concentrating more on the
development which is where i want to be
one of the things i told you about the
financial freedom challenge is i said
not only is it going to set you up and
you're going to get all the money you'll
make and the skills the money that
you'll make
most people say can you do a financial
freedom challenge with me because they
want
the money right the money's good the
deals the money whatever
but more important than that is the
skills that you'll get from the week
absolutely absolutely like like i hear
because
i'm still massively into like you know
personal development
i like all the people that you're
interested in grant cardone and
they say it you know if they were to
have all their money taken off him
but they still had this and what they've
learned they could make it back
yeah and i feel like i'm in that
position now you know i feel like
if i lost all of my money for whatever
reason
but i still kept my knowledge of what
i've learned
i can just do it again yeah you know the
piece of land that we've got there with
a jv where it was a no money down deal
i've actually got another one in salford
where i'm going to build six apartments
and
yeah six apartments on a piece of land
and he's got a shop next door which
we're gonna go up two stories which is
going through architecture now
which is the same thing so that
structure that you helped me
structure that that that deal that you
helped me do you know i've then just
took that and gone right okay cool
rinse and repeat copy and paste and then
i've done it again on another piece in
salford
yeah that's incredible and i've no doubt
you're gonna have all the beautiful
homes and the riverside and everything
that you've dreamed of because it's
happening now
yeah it's happening now on top of the
skills and the money
also the branding talk to me a little
bit about that because that's something
i think you underestimated at the
beginning maybe yeah
i mean brandon's massively important i
mean from the start i'd always
film myself going into properties and i
had close friends
you know and i'm sure people that are
watching this are gonna have the same
sort of things you know
close friends like why are you viewing
properties you know you're not buying
properties because they know you they
know how much
money i had back then i mean so they're
like you know why are you viewing
properties but i'd always film myself
in properties viewing them and it was
like a small mini version of homes under
the hammock rubbed walls and be talking
about like
the architray and talking about the
plastering and things like that
but i think the most important thing is
you've always got to brand yourself
if you don't if you don't tell everybody
who you are and what you do it's like
having a shop
with the shutters down yeah trying to
sell groceries yeah it's just not going
to work you've got to be brave
and i think some people do feel like
when they're starting out they're really
embarrassed
yeah to say they're a property investor
yeah because it's like you don't own any
property
but it's like no i'm speaking it out
yeah but what i was also talking about
was
like the actual video itself that we did
i mean what came of that
so the i mean i mean the exposure off
the ff challenge
and the eviction as well you know the
the branding that i got off the back of
that
it was credibility trust and and people
liked me
which i was honestly when i say i could
show you my phone
i honestly got about probably three to
four hundred messages off people saying
you're an inspiration
um i went for exactly what you went
through um
i can really fully relate to everything
that you went through how did you cope
with
you know with your partner and going
through that tough time and your son
like there were so many people that
had or were going through what i had
been through
yeah and it was incredible that you know
people were looking at me
as a source of inspiration like look if
he can do it you know i can
and i think that's absolutely amazing
because at the end of the day i am
nothing more than just a typical
northern lad yeah you know there's
nothing special about me except
i will say i have got you know i've got
a bit of some obama got a bit of balls
because
you do need to go out there and tell the
world who you are yeah like i'll say it
forever
tell the world who you are and what you
do and the funny thing is as well
is that you came through the eviction
and you had that challenge the refurb
challenge
yes but now if i'm struggling with a
refurb or if i've got an issue and it's
near your neck of the woods
who am i going to be picking up the
phone to yeah my man lauren hotwood from
hot woods homes
you know so you've had so you've
inspired so many people
and as a result of that you've been able
to do business
with so many people through the sourcing
development joint ventures
um what would you say to somebody that
was where you are now
a year ago quite simply if they've got
the drive
and they want to do something in
property you know whether it's deal
source and rents around essays
is to never give up because at the start
and even now
you know it's like this you have good
days you have bad days you have good
days you have bad days
just because you might have say four out
of the five bad days if you're gonna do
it on monday or friday because trust me
i don't i do seven days a week
you know if you're going to do it like
that just remember that they're not
always bad
they're not always bad and and you know
you might have
10 or 15 doors slammed in your face from
estate agents no we've not got any deals
no
i've seen 10 people like you today yeah
just got to keep going
what about what about someone that was
where you are sorry a year ago like just
as in just before you even got started
so they've not even got started but
they're just thinking is this real
25 grand a month from deal sourcing is
that even legitimate
is it possible for doing a big
development deal a six-figure
development deal
with no money some people are going to
be watching this skeptical
oh right okay see i don't even see that
because i'm so naive to it like i
wouldn't even see it as being skeptical
because if you're thinking like that
you're thinking too small
yeah like if you don't believe that it's
out there and you can do it i mean i
mean you're a perfect example
you know you've come from a
working-class background you've been in
property over 12 years
and you're smashing it you've started
off doing your deal sourcing and now
you're smashing massive developments
like you're living proof yeah there's
there's enough of us out there
to say that we can do i mean god we've
been to the moon haven't we as humans
like nothing's impossible you just have
a little bit of belief in you
get around the right people i think
that's the main thing
because let's go back so to the eviction
or even before the eviction i was trying
to get your attention
because i was watching you yeah i was
watching youtube i'd done you samuel 365
i was like
whatever this fella knows i need to know
yeah what do you mean by you trying to
get my attention so like you know i was
viewing properties i was always
tagging you on instagram yeah i was
always crediting you because people are
like where are you learning this from
what is deal sourcing
and and sometimes i couldn't even
explain it at the start because i i
didn't even know
so i was like just go and check out
samuel he's down here tagging
i saw that i saw you kept tagging my
instagram i was like who's this dude
because i've never met you
in real life yeah no never this is good
so i'd be sharing on my story
and it's i think that's really important
as well i think some people i was saying
this too early about money wasn't i i've
been a river
yeah yeah you know tell me about that so
it's the same like you know
if i had advert money from say deal
source and things like that
it's not really my money is it it's
everybody else's money because that
money then gets circulated i'd buy more
training because i've earned a couple of
grand
wow if i've just earned a couple of
grand let's invest a grand yeah get some
more training let's learn another couple
grand
so what i mean it yeah it circulates
around if i've earned
say 15 20 grand from deal sourcing over
a month or so or a couple of months
i can then invest that into a property
of my own yeah i can invest that into
builders they're getting paid
yeah i mean it circulates doesn't it
yeah money money doesn't just sit in one
place
and it should get money and then you
pass it to someone and then they pass it
and it just flows around
and the more you're investing in other
deals and other people the more comes
back and
and it's everyone's winning together
yeah and i think what i'm saying to you
is
there's a lot of people that are
seriously wealthy you know developers
they're making you know hundreds of
millions of pounds
you don't hear what they're doing they
keep me close to their chest what i'm
trying to do is create a trend
with people like anthony who's now a
developer yeah
dave taylor now a developer worked in
property before but now he's working for
himself doing deals these people are
doing big deals and development
i'm trying to create like a trend where
more and more people can be doing
development deals
successfully and and it it's accessible
yeah it's accessible and that's the key
thing as well because
if you are one of these you know rich
people that that holds their wealth
close to the chest and doesn't show
anybody your cards
like yo how can anybody else around you
do well
that's like saying you know i want to be
wealthy but i don't want nobody else to
be wealthy i'm going to enjoy my wealth
on my own
yeah but like what you're doing is going
well look this is how i've done it yeah
like you you can do it with me
like i'm showing you i've walked that
path yeah i'm showing you what to do
just follow my footsteps
yeah and and that's and i'll be honest
with you
you know what i'm like i'm not someone
who blows anybody's trumpet or anything
like that but i think that's the reason
why i was so connected to you from the
start was because
you were so clear on you on the way that
you spoke about
deal sourcing look just do this this and
this
that's how you get a deal yeah do this
this and this and that's how you sell it
to an investor
like i loved how crystal clear it was
how transparent it was from youtube
videos
so i knew that if i got onto the samuel
365 yeah that all the other golden
nuggets are going to be there where i
know exactly what to do with the
contracts
you know they're worth the waiting gold
yeah you know things like that
you know the yeah i still use it today
it's on my phone the um
viewing checklist yeah such a simple
thing but before i was walking around
looking at a property
going oh yeah this was in good condition
but i didn't look at the boiler i didn't
look at the
you know the the the electrics cupboard
but on your viewing checklist you know
you've got all them
tips and you know that make a massive
difference it's been the biggest high
over the last 12 months
um i mean apart from making you know the
businesses making really good money now
i'm fully independent
i would say that i am financially free
because i can do what i want when i want
you know i work on my own diary yeah you
choose to work hard
yeah but you could you could very easily
stop or systemize you're choosing to
yeah i mean i i i love it i think i
think that one of the biggest highs for
me was when
my son i heard i overheard my son at
rugby
talk to his little mate and say oh my
dad's a property investor and he builds
houses
and i just thought you know what that's
that's why i do it yeah get a bit
thinking about it now
oh sometimes you forget like you're why
now if you're why isn't if you've got
children obviously like if your why
isn't your children and what the hell
you're doing it for right i mean because
you're doing it for them
i'm trying to build generational wealth
i'm not just trying to build myself a
little bit of money
yeah i'm trying to build generational
wealth for him for his kids
you know i want to do big things in my
life i couldn't
be more proud of you bro and it the
success you've got couldn't have gone to
a better person
thank you mate we are going fernando's
in a few minutes
then you're coming on the crash courses
and some of the tour dates yeah i can't
wait for them like i said this has been
a year waiting you know when i got
involved with you the crash course is
just stuck was a lot down so
yeah you know i've been patiently
waiting for them to open back up so i'm
on all three of them well there's five
isn't it so i'm coming to three of them
yeah which i can't wait
people will see you around man yeah the
events and stuff
i can't wait to give them my time as
well yeah because that's me paying it
forward you know
it's like a book i bought your book as
well that's one of the first things i
did i forgot to mention
when i got on the samuel 365 um i've
seen like an advertisement on the
website for the book and it will thought
right i'm pretty buying that because
by low rent i i'm getting it i need to
know it i've read it and i've give it to
a friend now
i'm like i've read it pay the way
forward listen you need to read this
book and get on to this fella trust me
so when people come and see me at the
crash course i can't wait to spend time
with them and answer all the questions
that they've got
because i can't help i can't wait to
help somebody else as much as what
you've helped me
that's so great that's so great another
thing is as well
millionaire challenge what's that and
how's that going to be announced
oh well i mean the millionaire challenge
is falling off the back of the eviction
where we all won didn't we we all win
the eviction we all got the ff challenge
so the millionaire challenge is like the
ultimate prize
so we're going to get that out you've
got no idea what's in store by the way
for that
yeah yeah i don't even know so i'm
talking about some of that i don't even
know what the win is going to get yeah
it sounds good basically i'd say more
than anything it's doors opening
oh yeah you know to meet to meet a lot
of a-list
people and and and do some you know i
mean i i think that's probably
the biggest way and then also um some of
some other surprises but how's it going
to be announced and when because
obviously i haven't made my mind up yet
there's you
can lit david's connect evans is killing
it all in very different ways yeah
you know yeah so so how's that going to
be announced so i think the best way for
it to be announced would be on an event
wouldn't it if we set up an event
got loads of people there made it a
really cool fun q and a interactive
moment you know reunion yes on stage
yes get everybody there and that that's
the plan so that's going to be coming
real
soon and uh no i just want to say bro
mad
respect what does you what does your
partner rachel what does she think of
all this
it's crazy you know she sometimes can't
believe it herself
because you know and again we're gonna
go talk about money again but
you know money is the biggest financial
stress on anyone in the uk like i read a
stat
recently that said something about 500
pounds would make a massive difference
in most i'm sorry
500 pound is the difference between most
marriages breaking up and staying
together
wow which is unbelievable you know and
now
i'm there and i said it to richard i
feel like i'm on a football salary
yeah which is unbelievable so you know
there's no stress at home
there's there's a good future and i'm
building it for them
it's going to be hard for the first five
years because i'm locked in yeah
i'm locked in and then we can we can
rachel was very skeptical
massively yeah massive she was doing
what any mother would do and protect the
family in the protect the home
she was like you need to go search for
another job
indeed monster you need to get your cv
back out there
and and we was battling a little bit at
the start but obviously you know
i won that battle and the best way the
best way to
you know when you've got people around
you saying be careful be careful be
careful like the best way to deal with
it is just get rich
yeah let your results speak rather than
trying to win them over yeah yeah let
your results be
that's exactly what you've done so mate
big respect thank you so much one of the
best winners wednesdays we've ever done
in history so share the video around
drop a comment in for lauten connect
with him
hopwood homes group connect with lawton
come down to the one of our training
programs i'll leave a link in the
description
come down meet me meet lauren and other
people
and you can do the same thing too
absolutely can that's not what i said
people have been to the moon people have
done who have created electricity like
the amount of crazy things that have
been happened
that happened in the world that people
just thought was impossible this is
possible
you can do it you can have it all would
you agree bro absolutely absolutely
awesome
i'll see you guys there get get booked
on subscribe to the channel there's more
videos like this coming so subscribe
get booked on the training and i'll see
you real soon
get booked on